on her visit to china angela merkel is
trying to strike a balance between
business deals and human rights
at a meeting with president xi jinping
the chancellor promoted an innovative
bilateral partnership that would connect
german sino trade deals with chinese
political reform such as greater civil
liberty
it also includes other areas of
cooperation such as societal development
the development of the legal social and
educational systems
although that has not been agreed
several deals have been closed during
merkel's visit
volkswagen was one of the companies to
sign a contract to build two new plants
in china with a local partner
chinese economic growth may be slowing
but premier lee kichang said what is
most needed is reform not stimulus
china is still on the path to
modernization first and foremost that
means fundamental economic restructuring
he said beijing wants to see a broader
distribution of wealth and do more to
support smaller businesses
that approach will open new avenues for
german business
talks between beijing and berlin are
ongoing with the next government level
meetings planned for october
you